What’s up, guys? Today, we’re checking out the NES Classic Edition!
This comes out November 11th, so huge thank you, Nintendo, for sending me this early to check out. I’m super excited!
Even just yesterday, my sister was asking if I had a Super Nintendo or anything here to play some classic games,
and the irony; this shows up today!
So, I kinda can’t believe it…
I do have a Super Nintendo and a 64, but neither of them are set up.
Let’s open it up!
This is my childhood!
You can use two controllers. Another controller is sold separately.
It’s this little, sweet, NES— Oh my gosh!
Matthew! I’m having ﬂashbacks to my childhood!
Your childhood is only a year ago, you’re still a child.
Not interested.
I’m deﬁinitely gonna have to get a second controller.
We’ve got a power adapter here.
Oh, smells great.
HDMI cable.
Power cord.
Oh my god, this is tiny. This is like the size of an NES game.
Like, this is the size of what the cartridges used to be like.
Can you believe this?
Oh, wow… Holy moly.
Let’s set this thing up!
I can ﬁt all of these items in the palm of my hand.
This is incredible.
Here’s the problem! This cord’s really short!
Put that right there…
I think this might be a much better setup upstairs in my oﬃice,
but I wanna play it on this huge TV.
Alright, let’s power it on!
Deﬁnitely something I should play at my desk.
Oh my gosh! This is huge!
So there’s thirty total games on this little tiny guy…
We’re playing Mario.
Oh no! I wanted to get the mushroom!
Gimme that!
Shoot!
I’m in trouble…
Let’s play something else.
Oh my god! If you hit reset, it gets you back to the—
I’m having, like, ﬂashbacks to my childhood when, like, you couldn’t save games.
So, I would tell my mom, like, “You can’t touch this! You have to leave it on.”
And at the time, like, my parents, like, they always, still to this day,
shut everything oﬀ before they go to sleep, they turn lights oﬀ, like, unplug everything!
So, for them, leaving this on, I know for my dad, it drove him absolutely nuts!
Hi, honey!
Not right now, I’m playing a videogame.
So, this is pretty cool.
The display settings; to have a CRT ﬁlter, to make it look like some of those old school TVs with the scan lines,
the 4:3 ratio, or Pixel Perfect.
Got Super Mario Bros. 2! Oh—
Dreamboat!
Look at the scan lines! It looks like—
Can you guys see it?
You might just have to trust me that they’re there!
Yes, I will save you! I WILL SAVE YOU! PRINCESS, YOU PIG! NO! Aw, geez…
So, there’s thirty total games! I will put all of those games listed right there.
Let me know what you guys are most looking forward to.
And, I’m gonna go and edit this video now.
So, see you guys later! Bye!
“Guess what I found.
My iPhone 7 dongle!
It’s been missing for quite some time.
This also just came in today. This is a USB Type-C Hub.
It has many diﬀerent slots for pretty much everything that you’re gonna need.
If you guys got one of the MacBook Pros, or if you have one of the MacBook Airs…
You can power it with USB-C.
You got two diﬀerent SD card slots, and two USB—”